العام الماضي وبعد تخفيف قيود السفر بسبب
كورونا قدمت اندونيسيا عرضا في معرض موسكو
السياحيين الان حان وقت بالي لكن بالي لم
تكن تعلم ما ينتظرها من عرض كهذا راحه
بالروس يبدو انهم وجدوها في بالي باتت
بالي موسكو صغيره بعد قرار التعبئه من قبل
بوتين في اكتوبر وصل عدد الروسي الذين
دخلوا لاندونيسيا الى 12 الفا ازداد العدد
مع مرور الوقت ووصل الى 22 الفا في يناير
الماضي اكثر من اي جنسيه اخرى باستثناء
الاستراليه ليست هذه المشكله بل المشكله
في انتهاك قواعد التاشيرات مزاحمه
السائحين لوظائف السكان جرائم اجتماعيه
واقتصاديه هذا بحسب حاكم بالي ويان كوسترد
الذي قدم طلبا للحكومه بضروره الموافقه
مسبقا على طلب الروس والاوكرانيين
على تاشيرات بدلا من الحصول عليها عند
وصولهم ابرز الامثله على هذه الانتهاكات
تتعلق برجل روسي قاد سياره بيضاء فارهه في
انحاء بالي لكنه استبدل لوحه الترخيص
الرسميه باخرى مزيفه تحمل اسمه طبعا رحلته
السلطات الاندونيسيه لينضم الى 13 روسيا
رحلوا اعتبارا من منتصف مارس اي ما يقرب
من ثلث اجمالي المرحلين